what time is it it's fan theory time we
have found eight crazy fan theories
about High School Musical that will
leave you shook keep watching to find
out how these Disney Channel movies are
basically just like the purge
just remember all look at the purge does
musical ception hold on to your seats
this fan theory is a wild ride do you
remember the movie Inception it was all
about dreams within dreams within dreams
and it was crazy
this theory combines the inception
plotline with our favorite Disney
Channel musicals
reddit user Rock efface posted this
theory about four years ago they say
that the three High School Musical
movies are actually just one long high
school musical okay we know what you're
thinking of course the movies are
musicals about high school students but
that's not quite what we mean we are
saying that all three movies were really
just one long musical put on by high
schoolers the plots of all three movies
didn't happen they're just a story set
to the music they made a musical about a
musical let's look at the facts at the
end of High School Musical 3 the Casta
seems slowly walking toward a stage the
curtain falls behind them and they take
a bow um we're pretty sure that's not
how high school graduations happen why
would they take a bow if it's a movie
have they really just put on a giant
musical at East High there's also the
fact that high school musical doesn't
seem like any high school we've ever
seen it's pretty tame no one talks back
to teachers or starts a fight in the
hallway between classes it just doesn't
seem like a real school at all but wait
there's more
in the 1st and 3rd movie the characters
are in a musical and in the second movie
they are in a talent show that means
that they are musicals within a musical
within a musical about musicals whoa
this is making our head hurts
Chad Plus Ryan equals love everyone
knows that High School Musical is a love
story and Troy and Gabriella are
seriously couple goals and Chad and
Taylor are also a cute couple but there
is another couple hiding in plain sight
we can't believe we never noticed
move over Taylor chad has a new love
interest and it's Ryan yeah won't take
that as a compliment yep jock Chad and
the brother of Sharpay
we're totally together in High School
Musical 2 don't believe us check this
out
Ryan tries to convince Chad
to dance in the talent show why is he so
invested in getting Chad to dance there
are plenty of other people that leads to
one of the best songs and dances in the
entire second movie I don't dance
happens on the baseball field Chad
thinks that dancing is lame and he gives
Ryan a totally heated look he gets Ryan
to play ball with him there is some
definite tension there that you have an
intoxicating dance-off we can't believe
we missed their chemistry they might as
well have just asked each other out
right then and there
it was so obvious they were trying to
impress each other and they did and it
gets better that you decide to be
friends after this friends sure that's
all it was
they go get a casual snack together but
look at them Ryan is wearing Chad's
clothes and chad is wearing Ryan's um we
have questions Disney Channel when did
they switch clothes and more importantly
why we can only think of one reason they
would and it's not something that
belongs in a Disney movie but we're kind
of digging these two as a couple are
Chad and Ryan your new OTP Breaking Bad
the musical Breaking Bad isn't a show we
usually highlight here at the things
this show is definitely not meant for
kids it's a cable show about a guy named
Walter White's he was a normal guy who
had a sick kid and a baby on the way
then he finds out he has cancer and he
can't pay the bills he has some major
chemistry knowledge so he begins
dabbling and extremely illegal actions
to make ends meet this show is basically
the opposite of a Disney show but there
is an interesting connection between
Breaking Bad and High School Musical
they both take place in Albuquerque New
Mexico so let's assume that these two
shows exists in the same universe that
means there is definitely a dark side to
high school musical that we never see
but here's the other thing that will
blow your mind
Walter White was a teacher he taught
chemistry at a high school in
Albuquerque does that mean he taught at
East High before he taught at JP Winn
high school think about it he could have
been a teacher of Troy Gabriella and the
rest of the gang it might explain why
Gabriella is so good at chemistry can
you imagine a crossover between these
two fandoms chemistry it is the study of
what soon at the second equation reads
sixteen over pi it would be so weird
Sharpay was wronged one of
the most popular theories about High
School Musical isn't really a theory
it's just a different way of looking at
the story Twitter user at shar-pei was a
victim went on a long rant about how
sharp a was well of victim and we have
to admit it's pretty compelling
shar-peis whole life was theater and
music and she devoted most of her youth
to perfecting her skills she was
definitely the most qualified for the
musical in the first movie
she tells Troy and Gabriella through a
lot of supporting roles in the show and
she wasn't wrong
Sharpay had been working hard for years
to get the lead in the musical sharp and
Ryan's audition was way more fun and
upbeat than Troy and Gabriella also the
two stars showed up late in the audition
they weren't nearly as committed and
Troy really only auditioned because he
had a crush on Gabriella to make matters
worse they also showed up late the
callbacks
Sharpay was on time and ready to go Plus
Gabriella totally froze in her audition
she really was not ready to be the lead
in the musical people make fun of
Sharpay for being obsessed with theater
but once the basketball obsessed jock is
in the play it's suddenly cool that is
not fair it's really not okay to make
fun of someone for having a passion but
Sharpay doesn't get the role and she
still tells Gabriella
fregley
in theater that means good luck also
Sharpay only tried to sabotage their
roles in the play while Troy and
Gabriella friends tried to sabotage that
her whole relationship why is Sharpay
the bad guy political statements this
next theory is something right out of
your literature class according to some
people High School Musical is basically
a political statement against tyranny
it's like Animal Farm or hunger games
both at least it's similar but it has a
lot more singing and dancing both Troy
and Gabriella had been stereotypes by
their interest story is a total jock
Gabriela is supposedly a nerd because
she likes science but they both want to
break free from these roles they want to
show that they are more than just a jock
and a nerd and they want to show their
friends that they don't have to date
within their social group some people
have pointed out that this is like
stories where heroes rise up against an
oppressive government there's some
government theory about the middle class
rising up and getting new rights we can
kind of see the parallels but if it came
down to a fight between Katniss and
Gabriela
our money would be on Katniss twinkle
town was super uncalled for twinkle town
is the name of the musical written by
calcium the first movie we can't quite
get an idea of what the play is all
about
it all seems really random reddit user
Belisarius 25 has really broken twinkle
town down and they think that Kelsey
wrote a really dark musical they think
that the couple in the play Arnold a
mini try illegal substances then they
get involved in a risky business and end
up running from the law here's the
evidence the sets costumes and stuff
don't make any sense there's a city
background but there's also a camel the
theory suggests that the random stuff
like the camel was actually a
hallucination the song what I've been
looking for is supposed to be really
serious but fans pointed out that its
lyrics could have a double meaning pop
to the top is totally random they're
wearing fancy clothes and they randomly
speak Spanish the person who came up
with this theory says this could be a
metaphor for dubious activities in fact
they believe Spanish lines were inserted
to the plot to him towards dealings with
Spanish cartels the song even mentions
showing muscle which could mean using
force to intimidate people then there's
breaking free the lyrics sound happy
but it's sung in a really
add tone what if breaking free is
actually about leaving their illegal
pasts behind or breaking out of jail
whoa now that's one dark theory do the
robot okay we aren't actually talking
about the dance move called the robot
but this next fan theory is wild
reddit user ppy two-three-four has a
really detailed theory on why Troy and
the rest of the Wildcats team are robots
we know what you're thinking but here's
out in the world of high school musical
basketball is a big deal
coach has a team of robots he thinks
that adding human emotions and empathy
to one will make him a better player so
he makes Troy Troy truly believes that
he's human allowing the team to go to
high school was all part of her projects
they were trying to teach robot Troy how
to feel when Troy meets Gabriella he
begins to learn about love
coach and the other robots are not happy
he was not intended to learn about love
they try to sabotage his relationship
with Gabriella they pay off with her
clicks to interfere - the math nerds
plant a camera that can live stream to a
laptop this was really advanced
technology in 2006 but if they got the
tech from coach it would make sense but
robot Troy has gone totally rogue and
his love for Gabriella robot Troy is
beyond repair but he's important for
robot research so the coach can't
destroy him he hooks up his cyberbrain
to a computer robot Troy's brain lives
out a fantasy life with Gabriella where
Gabriella is left alone never knowing
she fell in love with a robot
this theory is detailed but it's pretty
crazy a more perfect AAU this last
theory is a pretty popular one and it
basically says that High School Musical
is a kid-friendly version of the purge
if you aren't familiar with that movie
here's the basic idea one night a year
everything is legal there are no
consequences you can imagine how violent
the world gets Reddit user Skye was the
robot notice that High School Musical is
pretty tame you don't see the students
doing anything illegal of course it is a
Disney movie but sky was the robot
wanted a better in universe explanation
they came to the conclusion that High
School Musical takes place in an
alternate world without laws the
characters regularly do things that
should have consequences but they never
do for instance they trash the whole
school to be
the second movie that just isn't okay in
the real world shar-pei bribes mr.
Fulton to make the other workers
miserable there are things that he does
that should be illegal in the third
movie Troy gets accepted into Juilliard
but he never even applied his mother
committed fraud and applied for him this
is seriously unethical and illegal in
our world that's worth up to 10 years in
prison but she never faces the music all
these illegal things are seen as totally
okay the only explanation is that there
are no laws which of these theories are
your favorites let us know in the
comments new around here hit that
subscribe button for more awesome videos
about the things thanks for watching
we'll catch you next time
[Music]